[Music]
welcome back everybody thanksgiving is
around the corner and
you can celebrate la bonita style that
means flavor and great prices i hung out
with the team today to find out more
check it out
it is a crazy time around the world but
still so much to be grateful for right
celeste there's always something to be
thankful and grateful for this year so
we are celebrating thanksgiving with
lavonita and i must say lavonita style
because i see some pre-marinated
chicken and pork so tell us what you got
for us so we got it all ready for you we
know that these are very stressful times
and we want to make it as easy
and as enjoyable as possible this
thanksgiving we know how special
this thanksgiving is for everyone so la
bonita has
our own lavonita marinade for our
turkeys
all you have to do is turn on the oven
and put it in there
my kind of turkey it's amazing and if
you don't like the turkey we also have
pork and we also have chicken that is
available all of
this are on special we have the chicken
for 16.99 the pork went for 29.99
and our beautiful turkeys already uh
marinated are 39.99 wow and i did hear
that
the average family spends about fifty
dollars on thanksgiving for dinner
it's exciting you're already below your
average shopping at la bonita and
you can't even afford that if your
family needs extra help you're also
doing something for them too right
we always have something special to give
to we especially for thanksgiving we
are giving out about 30 turkish this
marinated one so you don't even have to
do anything but just go online
and check out the details that we have
but if you are also like me
which i like to have my own marinade we
have this beautiful
baby turkey over here well i wouldn't
call it baby but right
through this weekend starts on friday
all the way to thanksgiving is 79 cents
the pound for this turkey oh
yes oh my gosh i would ask you what your
secret is but you know
i know you can't give everybody the
secret no because i
literally just put all the ingredients
together and throw some wine and that's
my turkey
i like that i like that idea okay and
also because it is the holidays i'm
i was expecting some tamales to be on
the table we always have tamales
we always have tamales for you mr well
has him
ready pre-made for you
now now the holiday with lavonita is
complete
and now it's complete okay there you go
the chicken wine
and just so you know you know we are all
about safety at lavonita so please you
can go online and
pre-order your tamales oh that's great
yes and we also do
curbside pickup for everything in the
store
so you can curbside pick up a marinated
turkey
for thanksgiving yes you can't get any
easier more convenient than that
you just literally have to go in there
order it and pick it up
to have an awesome thanksgiving there
you go cheers
happy thanksgiving everybody happy
thanksgiving
oh this is good let's see
[Music]
oh my god oh yeah i'm ordering mine
yeah definitely i'm just wearing them
these are amazing
i've definitely eaten about three of
those today there are seven la bonita
supermarkets in the vegas valley
click on bonitamarkets.com to find the
location nearest
you